we've got something interesting for you
today I am joined now by Jeremy
Montana's who is a former Trump
supporter who was actually featured on a
panel on CNN's new day on August 7th and
on that panel Jeremy explained why he at
one point did support Donald Trump but
since is no longer a supporter of
Trump's and since then he has been
accused of being a plant by the so
called fake news CNN and has even
received death threats from followers of
the president so Jeremy first of all
thanks for talking to us today
so let's first just figure out how did
CNN find you in order to invite you to
this panel of former and current Trump
supporters according to them I had
posted something a while back that stood
out to them as being a former Trump
supporter I have no idea what it was
that they saw but they wanted three or
six people on a panel three that support
him three that used to support him but
as I felt it I felt like I was the only
one there that actually did not support
him okay and when they contacted you did
they say anything about the specifics of
what you would be expected to say were
you coached in any way or was it
basically the premises you are a former
Trump supporter and you'll participate
on a panel just the premises that I was
a former Trump supporter and I would
participate on the panel there was no
training coaching at balls and were you
paid for the appearance I was not okay
good
so you show up at this panel and the
questions are relatively unremarkable
the people that still support Trump or
asked why do you support Trump what do
you like about about you doing that's
good you were asked about other elements
and opinions of why you used to support
Trump and white why you no longer do did
anything about the dynamics of the
entire panel feel concerning to you
inauthentic or did it seem as though
everybody on the panel was just giving
their genuine thoughts and feelings kind
of frightening
that these supporters have and what
lengths they go to to believe what you
know I consider their false news and
their fake news and it was very hard for
me to express my own opinions when
you're surrounded by basically five
Trump supporters because they're
constantly cutting you off and I made it
a point not to do that to any of them so
after the panel you start receiving all
sorts of criticism including that you
were a plant and death threats through
what means where most of the messages
coming was it through social media that
people find your phone number where
people showing up at your house with a
headline on their website that
specifically said former Trump supporter
calls president monster which is I did
call my monster and it went onto YouTube
and I started getting the defamation
they're being called a CNN plant and
after a crisis actor basically what
David hog was going through is what they
started doing to me I continue to do to
me and then I was starting to get death
threats on there which a lot of them
have been removed thank goodness but as
far as getting personal deference I
received a few sent to me by my own
email yes no phone calls oh okay so what
state do you live in and and did you
vote in and sort of would have been your
political beliefs for you know the pre
Trump era I've always been a liberal
Democrat I live in the state of
California and the reason why you're
probably wondering that I vote for him
in the first place yeah is because I
couldn't get myself to vote for Hillary
Clinton I'm gonna be honest about that
at the time I looked at her as a status
quo candidate I looked at her as just
being a moderate candidate I wanted
somebody that was more for the people I
looked at her as a criminal as being a
criminal
I just thought voting for a
non-politician might be the best bet and
it turns out was the biggest mistake
I've ever made that's interesting so you
saw Trump this New York City billionaire
as a guy who was more for the people
than Hillary Clinton when he spoke to be
a citizen because he didn't speak in
this I guess you can say prim and proper
manner I don't know I think it's more
also because this was probably the worst
you know set of candidates we've ever
had or especially in my lifetime so it
was a very very you know difficult
choice to make but what's funny is that
you know back then I used to think to
myself well you know I don't want to
ever have to say voting for Hillary
Clinton now if you're talking to me you
asking the same question it's the
biggest mistake I've ever made and I
can't go back on that were there any
issues so a lot of what you're talking
is about sort of the dynamics how Trump
spoke versus how Hillary Clinton spoke
and the sort of feeling whether one is
more or less for the people as you said
as a Liberal Democrat did you agree with
Trump on any issues he was basically
spouting out racism and what now know
I'm actually a I'm Hispanic
I grew up in Mexico for half of my life
but I didn't think I thought that once
he would come into office he would
change his too and I thought that he was
trying to just win a base over and that
he just wanted certain votes and I did
you know honestly I can't think of there
was some interviews I saw him say where
he wants to give you know healthcare or
make it for everybody and stuff like
that so yeah those issues I didn't agree
with because I believe in universal
health care I did I did not one minute
think that would become the nightmare
that it's become having him in office
but wait a second Jarrett so you thought
Trump wanted universal health care he
said in some interviews that I saw he
was either he was gonna change the
Bhalla cure but he was gonna make it to
where you know everybody's gonna have
some
than grade everybody's gonna have a
great plan you know and that you know
that's struck out to me because
universal health care is actually my
main my main issue and then it just went
down to the fact that you know I mean if
I want to be really honest about this I
can say that it could have been more of
an anti Hillary vote but I didn't I
didn't start my my what's the word
regret for voting for him entirely until
he started doing what he was doing on
the southern border that's what did it
for me so once it as you mentioned you
grew up part of your life in Mexico and
you're Hispanic once it got to that
point that's when you started to regret
your vote yes and not was it about that
you know from minions want you to
believe these kids didn't come with
their parents and whatnot you know I I
think that's nonsense and he may be some
dinner but that doesn't give them any
right to shove kids and cages and
separate them from you know it's
inhumane I can't believe that this
country has come to thatx you know it
reminds me of concentration camps
reminds me of what they did to the
Japanese during World War two and not
only that but his racism was just off
the chain even with Puerto Rico that's
an island that's home by the USA after
that hurricane he called them whiners so
that they need to help themselves how
they not have brown skin and had it been
a white island would he have helped them
I don't really believe he would have
yeah I mean I don't disagree with you I
guess what I'm trying to figure out and
what I find interesting here is well let
me couch my next question with this
first question how closely would you say
you followed the election up to November
of 2016
like would you say you followed the
election very closely or casually or not
very closely I was originally for Bernie
Sanders and then once Clinton us
basically rigged the primary again
that's you know we've got the nomination
that's all I feel about it yeah that's
what I started looking more at Trump and
watching his interviews and watching his
speeches and he just seemed like a
strong president he had a strong
presidential presence at that time but a
lot of this stuff has been vulgar you
know I'm never gonna deny that you know
well I guess what I'm was kind of
thinking you know you said that the
things that kind of broke the straws
that broke the camel's back for lack of
a better term were the reaction to
Puerto Rico and and then also what's
going on at the southern border Trump
said during the campaign Mexico's not
sending our best they're sending rapists
and criminals and some I assume are good
people he said he wanted to ban Muslim
immigration to the United States
I guess what as someone who says you
followed the election closely I'm
surprised that the the straw that broke
the camel's back was something that we
saw the entire campaign you know right
into the campaign maybe two months
before the election even happened and
you know I mean I live with pro-trump
you know people you know in my own home
who kind of convinced me to just give
him a shot give him a chance you know
see what he does and I believe in that I
believe in giving people chances and
seeing if they're gonna you know do
something good why did you apply that
same thing to Hillary Clinton right
because you you had some skepticism of
Hillary Clinton but at least on paper
her views were closer to yours what
about giving her a chance right I guess
I'm trying to understand how as a burnt
you know you and I both supported Bernie
Sanders originally yeah I'm trying to
figure out how your openness to giving
people a chance ended up with you voting
for the guy whose beliefs were the
furthest from yours I think it's because
of how just like angry I was at the
Democratic Party for snubbing Bernie and
I think I think that you know it was
more of some people have asked me you
know when it also and though would you
say that
was an anti Hillary vote yeah I would
say that it was but I did at least give
him a chance up to a point because I've
always said that I don't like him as a
person I never cared for I've never
thought that he was a good person but I
wanted to see you know how he might be
doing as a president cuz we've got
plenty of presidents that weren't good
people but that ran the country pretty
well but again if your complaint was
that Hillary didn't seem to you I guess
to say she wasn't a good person she
didn't seem for the people you would
think that applying the exact same logic
you did to Trump which is it doesn't
matter whether she's a good person or
not she might do good things and let's
give people a chance I'm I'm still just
confused how you got to the vote you got
wait
okay different dif so what about
applying that approach in 2016 why not
vote for Jill Stein for example or Gary
Johnson if the idea was not to support
Hillary Clinton you know I believe in
voting I believe it's our right to do
that let me ask you this as you know
there was talk during the election after
Bernie Sanders did not get the
Democratic nomination there was talk of
a vote a significant voting bloc that
were Bernie supporters who would end up
voting for Trump mathematically it was
not a common thing but you you actually
did it right do you know other Bernie
sapote supporters in California that
ended up voting for Trump yes you did
yes and what was their reasoning for
doing that it was it was anger with
Hillary Clinton was it more anger with
Hillary or
more anger with the DNC I think both
Debbie you know Debbie Schultz and just
the whole thing it was just a big mess
you know as far as people's feelings
because they you know people like myself
I mean I really felt like a person that
could have been the greatest president
in my lifetime that could have actually
helped people like me and when I say
that I'm talking about you know people
that don't aren't rich and whatnot I
mean really could have made a change in
a very positive change and I think that
just people were just sick of it they
were just tired of you know every single
every four years we get the same kind of
garbage on the White House and we really
wanted something different we wanted
real progressive change Wow
Jeremy after the CNN panel what was the
dynamic like with the other participants
most of whom are still supporters of
Trump did they say anything to you were
they angry with you or was a cordial no
we you know we became good friends for
the day that we were hung out afterwards
and we had a really good time you know
everybody went their separate ways in
the end there was no arguing there was
no fighting so it was a very it was
cordial I enjoyed myself
well the death threats are absolutely
horrible are you I mean I don't I don't
want you saying more than you're
comfortable but are are you taking are
there some that you feel need to be
taken seriously are you sort of taking
action about some of this stuff yes when
we BC on Univision and I took that very
seriously I made a police report on that
and the PD over in my city you know did
everything they could they came over and
you know got my information I gave them
a copy of the email and you know we just
went from there I mean they told me to
not be too frightened because it's not
frequent that I'm getting personalized
emails sent to me like that but yeah I
mean they actually said you know I
wished I knew I wish I knew were you
it's like you know I kill you myself
well I was writing wow we have been
speaking with Jeremy Montana's who is a
former Bernie supporter who voted for
Trump regrets the vote and then was
called a CNN plant for merely stating
that that is now a vote that he regrets
quite quite a situation we find
ourselves in in 2018 Jeremy
really appreciate you talking to me
today and telling me the entire story
I appreciate you thank you so much for
the opportunity in the honor